Oh Destin the entire Permian Basin
region have been shattered over the past
24 hours hearts have been broken we want
people of the Permian Basin to know that
all of Texans stand with you and embrace
you at this time of challenge we are
here today and will be here every day
until this community is pieced back
together but we know that words alone
are inadequate words must be met with
action I want to thank the police chief
for his tireless efforts over the past
24 hours in the robust and heroic
response that he Deanna's bill in law
enforcement agencies and officers
utilized to bring the gummin down and to
quickly deescalate the challenge and to
literally save lives that could have
been lost had it not been for the action
of the collaborative effort by law
enforcement
among those miners we cannot think
enough all of the first responders from
all of the law enforcement agencies
involved in this process to ensure that
they were going to be able to do what
was necessary to restore safety in this
community as governor I particularly
want to thank the Texas Department of
Public Safety for what they did we talk
about this all the time and that is
there is no such thing as a routine stop
the way all this began yesterday what is
whip what would be categorized as a
routine stop by the Texas Department of
Public Safety only for that stop to
immediately escalate into gunfire
by this killer with a DPS officer bein
injured in the process so I appreciate
the way that the Texas Department of
Public Safety steps up every single day
always prepared knowing that the lives
on the line any stuff they make ensuring
safety in our communities across the
state